what's going on guys
the summers just about over kids going
back to school and the summer movie
season has come to an end so we're gonna
do a little summer movie wrap-up we had
an awesome panel a couple months ago
talk to us about their summer movie
predictions guess what they're back
first you know him from the schmoes know
on YouTube Kristian harloff bitching all
up when's the Sunna poll said no one she
is one of the delightful hosts from
clever movies
Aaron Robinson and he's the head badass
a badass digest Devin Faraci hi I'm
gonna take that and save it for later so
guys uh first thing that comes to your
head when I say summer box office each
Apes bomb ah yes slow boxes great movie
slow box oh I agree with that getting a
movie that you feel was severely
underrated as it tomorrow edge of
tomorrow yeah it was a great film
it had a terrible title it was like yeah
this week on edge of tomorrow we'll Mora
admit that she loves that yeah right
this is why would you call it that any
huge disappointments out there my
biggest disappointment was the amazing
spider-man 2 I have to say I had found
my list for selfish reasons but um you
know I was really holding out that this
was gonna be the movie that Alex
Kurtzman and Roberto Orci could pull it
pull it through and make a really great
movie and it just was very painful
doesn't watch Devon I think you showed
the most foresight in regards to the
number one movie of the year you had
guardians of the galaxy the highest on
your list and number two to backtrack
and talk to us from about where you were
coming from on that I'm a slobbering
Marvel fanboy I believe that people
really wanted something different they
wanted that fun tone they wanted that
space action it didn't feel like
anything else that was out there and I
saw that coming I knew what the movie
was in advance and I had a weird feeling
that that's what the audience wanted
okay what man that shocked me because I
thought it would do well people worry
there's an early buzz about it for sure
but I remembered having that
conversation you thought it would do
decent Christian it was number seven on
your
I thought it was gonna out well I
thought it I thought it was gonna do
about 55 opening weekend and it
shattered that I would have never in a
million years thought it would have been
the top grossing movie of the summer
yeah Erin you had his number 5 I had it
as number 5 most anticipated movie of
the summer I have to say I didn't love
guardians as much as everyone else did
oh do you think it was so refreshing
though and I thought it was really fun
time hold up a second you just said you
hated guardians wait I told you
off-camera that just a sec behind it
straight that I didn't hate what do you
have against raccoons it's you know what
I could say something Java rocket Groot
is lame I did America loves Groot
I just wanted to see more impressed
pammi was better than Guardians oh that
I can get on board with I was skeptical
about putting it higher than number five
yes it was so new and I just felt like I
felt like marble does it right so I was
confident but I was just kind of
anticipating you know I really wasn't
sure what to expect but blew my mind I
mean I can't believe it did as well as
it didn't you are the only one of the
four of us that did not have
transformers at number one you had it at
number two people keep going to see
these movies and every time it's just
like oh maybe it'll be okay and you go
watch it you're like this is the same
stuff over and over again I'm so over it
there's no story line it's just a bunch
of action I feel like it's a painful
experience like it's like I feel like
you're a masochist to go in there and
get bludgeon for all that time I think
America is really interested in the
Romeo and Juliet law that was the most
amazing part of the whole movie movie
stops dead so a guy can pull out a card
from his wallet and say this is actually
why I can legally bone your underage
daughter and you're like what is this
movie yeah I just this movie hate me
personally yeah feels like in hailey the
movies just like that's what it at
Michael Bay going got chicken yeah but
maybe Americans are coming around a
little bit because this was the lowest
grossing Transformers film out of the
for I mean doesn't make a difference
because the reality is this is the
really sad part about the movie
right now yeah it did not make as much
here as the other ones did but it killed
overseas yeah we are actually we're
entering a world where there Halloween
will be making movies for foreign
audiences you don't want to have to
translate too much yeah lotions travel
further that way yeah plot lines get
much simpler and dumber and they're just
gonna really focus on like the heroic
Chinese government aspect of it and
we're gonna be sitting here going from
American movies and they're having all
tailored for foreign audiences really
strong movie that we haven't talked a
lot about yet dawn of the Planet of the
Apes Christian I know you're my favorite
movie of the year so far I love I love
that movie I was looking forward to it I
loved rise and and dawn just blew that
out of the water what I loved about that
movie is that the trailer sold us a
completely different movie so when you
sat down to watch it you were surprised
at every single turn yeah and I just I
loved it we don't ever see that anymore
it was so refreshing
yeah really dug it it would be so good
that it has a useless dumb kid character
and it doesn't even hurt the movie yeah
that's how good that excellent another
flick we haven't talked about yet
turtles I was a nightmare on film it was
a horrible experience it was a dismal
grueling piece of crap but it was
perfect for a little nine year olds who
don't know any better and that's why I
made that must be me I must be the
perfect 9 year old that doesn't know any
better cuz I didn't think it was great
but it was fun it was it was better look
I think my expectations were like way
down here and the the crapper so I think
that watching it I was like ok it wasn't
the worst movie I've ever seen yeah a
couple more that ended up in this
summer's top 10 that we haven't
mentioned yet Maleficent Oh worry it
just it wasn't that wasn't Maleficent
one of the greatest Disney villains of
all time and she knows it no longer a
villain yeah I don't know why you decide
you're gonna take this beloved story and
then at the end go oh no this is totally
different that time actually that was my
brother it's crazy why would you do that
right actually like this story I haven't
talked about x-men yet oh yeah forget
about x-files like a second best movies
II yeah it's awesome yeah you loved it
this point really enjoyed it it was a
nice change to not have it all be about
Wolverine right I mean it was me had a
pick at a prominent position it wasn't
me I mean it was kind of mad
Marine was sent back into the past they
changed the character who went back into
the past to make er be real - why you're
saying it wasn't a wolf it wasn't a
third Wolverine origin story but there
was a Quicksilver which was so good oh
man that was one of the best scenes of
like all superhero movies in my opinion
like and talked so good I just thought
it was a perfect blend of what because I
loved first class
I loved it was the perfect blend between
first class and the x-men that we first
got introduced to we had strong debate
on the show about Godzilla where do you
guys stand what you think Godzilla from
beginning really fun and then great
ending but the boss battle at the end
was some pretty awesome photos one of
those movies where I really liked it but
if somebody didn't like it I'm like I'll
get it right yeah sometimes you can be
like no you're wrong I'm like I know I
get I totally get why you didn't like it
it worked for me but I totally
understand why everybody else didn't
like it yeah it makes absolute sense it
was beautifully shot I have to say that
I liked the action but this worry for me
was just kind of bland the one comedy
that made the top ten this summer 22
Jump Street I love this movie and it has
the best credit sequence oh yeah yeah of
this millennium yeah this millennium
with a Boheme we didn't have a huge
animated runaway hit summer How to Train
Your Dragon was number 10 I thought it
would be up higher than that yeah sure
yeah we do have a few movies this summer
that parents could actually take their
kids to I think maybe Maleficent filled
that void for some people um but yeah I
was really shocked okay guys let's get
down to brass tacks the top 10 lists
only one of us correctly chose all ten
villains oh I had 8 out of 10
correct yeah I crapped the bed with
Tammy and a million ways China lists
Kristian harloff had nine out of ten
correct Devin Faraci had nine ten
correct he had edge of tomorrow on his
list everyone
I like the Aaron Robinson had ten out of
ten oh yes yeah did the damn thing my
window was a good clue t-shirt um you
get ready to pick something from the
collection is the champion the last time
I want anything was in fifth grade and I
was a Sega Genesis because I read the
most books in elementary school also we
put the call out to you guys the viewers
to give us your list and we had several
people who had 10 out of 10 but now we
got to go to the tiebreaker who
positioned the film's correctly and it
all boils down to 22 Jump Street and
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles we'll know
everything when the dust settles but
until then let's take a look at our
finals congratulation guys great job one
of you will be wearing a screen junkies
t-shirt but just all of you should know
that you're better than me I'm human
garbage compared era not so special
anymore all those people chose 10 but
you're the best we got names so what was
your favorite movie this summer what was
the biggest disappointment of the summer
let us know in the comments section
below we want to know what you thought
oh and let me ask you this do you need
more screen junkies in your life well
you can watch every screen junkies
episode and every honest trailer on
great comms new app that's available on
Xbox one and Xbox 360 again I got to
thank this awesome panel Kristian
harloff check out schmoes know and AMC
movie talk Erin Robinson clever movies
Devin Faraci if you're not reading
badass digest you are a bad human being
okay um I'm Hal Rudnick thanks for
watching screen junkies hit me up on
all right if a man were to make love to
a black hole mm-hmm what would happen
probably not going to come back from
that experience yeah it looks like it
once you go black never come back
exactly